i think it's still it's still right
there you know to be had i mean it's uh
um
you know it's a great opportunity
tomorrow night to start uh
you know with the division opponent and
uh and try to try to capture that
because you know if you win your
division you know good things happen you
know later in the season so
it's obviously part of part of one of
our you know our focus and then one of
our goals each season
that's doug peterson coach of the
philadelphia eagles and i'll take some
exception chris sims to the idea that
winning your division automatically
means good things happen all it means is
you're guaranteed hosting a playoff game
and that playoff game very well may be a
wild card game and then you have to go
on the road against a much better team
the thing i don't like about the current
structure of the nfl with two
conferences four divisions per
conference and four teams per division
all you have to be is the best of four
crappy teams and you host a playoff game
possibly against a much better team that
has to come to you i don't like that and
it looks like the nfc east may be the
poster child this year of that dynamic
because it very well could be that the
eagles washington the cowboys or the
giants and the giants are still alive
because everyone else is so bad will end
up hosting a very good five seed coming
out of the nfc yeah well that that
certainly could be but that's the way
the rules that are set up i don't have
any issue with that i mean oh wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
that's the way the rules are set up so
yesterday you want to get into a big
fight with me over how the rules are set
up as it relates to unnecessary
roughness and roughing the passage but
now you're like well that's how the
rules are set up
whether you're on board with the rules
or not we didn't change anything they've
changed the way they call those plays
that you're talking about okay so
they've changed the way they called them
i regret the last 30 seconds of my life
you should have because now you're going
to hear about it okay so just because
the last 15 months of my life the front
office of the nfl now and you're going
to stick up yeah that's why yeah oh
that's yeah but i have a long track
record of defending the nfl and lately i
feel like you are best buddies with them
it's unbelievable so okay but either way
yes do you think this is the best budget
and who cares about
okay yes if you win the division um yes
there's something to that you should be
rewarded with a home football game and
how many times have we seen wild card
teams in general win the super bowl so
uh not often well we've seen we've seen
it the giants have done it twice i mean
we're talking about a team that's done
it twice in the last 10 years so
they've done it the packers have done it
the pittsburgh steelers have done it so
that's it that's the list out of 52
super bowls congratulations you've
identified all this for modern day and
it's happened four times in the last 12
years so it's a different league now
yeah you can't count the first 40 years
without salary cap and free agency
that's not the same same type of setup
anymore but here's the key though here's
the key here i'm going to change the
subject on you the four teams that have
pulled it off all had quarterbacks
playing at a ridiculously high level the
giants currently don't and i don't think
eli manning is anything close to what he
was in 2011 or 2007. so even if the
giants end up winning this division i
don't have faith that the giants could
progress as far as the other giants
teams that had to do it the hard way did
yeah i i understand that but i don't
think any giants fans had faith in eli
that he was going to turn it around
those years in the playoffs too because
he didn't play great in the regular
season in 2007 or 2011 either but then
he caught on fire you know even hey eli
he's got some big game magic to him
there's no denying that i mean even the
boat trip wild card weekend a few years
ago up in green bay he wasn't worth a
damn that year with the giants when they
went in 10-06 and snuck into the wild
card round either but he went up in that
playoff game and played well all i'm
saying is the giants are not out of this
yet they're not as poor as it's been as
dysfunctional as it's been over the last
week they win tonight okay then you got
the falcons next week i mean the falcons
are a dumpster fire right now you got
the redskins i still think that's a
winnable football game the 49ers then
the bucks i mean i'm just saying
there's a chance there's a chance that
they can turn this around uh i i if you
made me bet mike i would say no they
don't but uh this this schedule sets up
for them to make a little run here and
get back even with the the rest of the
field here
are you still a giants fan dating back
to your your childhood of course i am
yes
every week's like 100 because i have
friends in the league and things that i
root for at times but
as a whole i am a giants fan
so at what loss what would it be five
six seven uh how many does it take like
let's say they lose tonight and go to
one and five is that enough for you to
say you know what they're better off
just losing as many as they can getting
the first overall pick drafting the best
quarterback out there and having their
own patrick mahomes baker mayfield to
pair with seguan barkley and otto
beckham jr at what point do you start
rooting for that well i i don't know i i
don't know if i
i'm really not a rooter of that in
general because just being in an nfl
locker room i just don't even think
that's
a thing i i really don't i know it's not
well i know it's not a thing among the
players but i think it's definitely a
thing among owners they tried to do it
last year by putting eli manning on the
bench it has happened it's a dynamic no
one's ever going to admit to it because
there would be a congressional
investigation if anyone ever did but i
believe it's smart
on the bench for the exact opposite
reason because they wanted to win a
football they were tanking they were
tanking but they were tanking and no
they were not they're ben
trying to win a game because he knew he
was going to be fired and the guy that
he had a quarterback wasn't playing well
so he had to change him
i i think that they were tanking and i
think that it's good business to tank if
i owned an nfl team and that team was
out of it and i didn't have a long-term
answer at quarterback and i saw that
what happened with the rams and the
eagles in 2016 and i saw what happened
with patrick mahomes and mitchell
trubisky and deshaun watson in 2017 and
i see what's happening with baker
mayfield and sam darnold and josh allen
and josh rosen in 2018 i'd be saying hey
let's earn the highest possible draft
pick that we can so we can get our
franchise quarterback and i don't know
why that's some sort of a weird taboo i
know the players are never going to do
it sometimes the coaches are in on it
like lovey smith was with the buccaneers
back in 2014 when they tanked in the
second half of the season-ending game
against the saints to ensure that they
would have the number one overall pick
in 2015 when they took jameis winston
but i don't know why it's not more
prevalent i think it is more prevalent
than anyone would ever admit the players
aren't going to be in on it the owners
and the gm's are the ones who realize
the value and i think for the giants you
go to one and five tonight
if i'm a giants fan i'm saying all right
it's hey look i i i can process the fact
that this season is lost let's win next
season and every season beyond that by
securing the highest possible draft pick
and going out and getting our franchise
quarterback i mean it's openly
acknowledged in other sports i don't
know why it's some big secret or some
big taboo in the nfl it should be a
foundation of good business for a team
that is trying to turn around years of
under achievement well yeah it just it's
a harder sport to tank in because
there's more moving pieces no it's not
no it's not you put the second string as
another we want to see we want to see
how who who's the backup now is it is
kyle back up
oh god we want to see how kyle oletta
plays yeah that's what they were trying
to do last year okay but then and
everybody lost their minds because thou
shalt not disrespect eli manning your
whole team fall apart they'll give up
you're gonna have dysfunction in the
locker room your first year head coach
is not gonna be liked you're gonna have
to talk about
to fire our new to get a new head coach
because yes because the front office
wanted to tank is what you're saying so
all your s it's all theory conjecture
bull crap bull crap bull crap
players coaches are going to game plan
to win games no matter what and you
can't just throw a season you talk about
player safety everything about it but
you'll have major dysfunction with an
nfl organization if that was the case
head coaches are going to continue to
game plan it's going to go on pat
shurmur's gravestone about his record
when all said and done you mean right
right next to nine and 23 from his time
in cleveland well yeah of course he does
it exactly so there's my point so yeah
oh yeah he's gonna throw it when guys
like you are remembering his wrecker
right off the top of it and they're
going to use that against them and then
you're going to tell them to tank this
year and then next year they draft a
quarterback and they get off to a bad
start and you're going to go his his
career record as a head coach is this
he's horrible we got to get him out of
here so no
pat shurmur and the giants don't listen
to mike florio keep fighting and keep
playing football
yeah and and keep wondering who your
quarterback is going to be after you
like that's an issue at some point
you've got to bottom out right that's my
point this is your golden opportunity if
the season is lost and if you lose
tonight i think it's fair to say the
season is lost at one in five go ahead
and let the bar now i'm not saying put
in kyle loletta now but i think that
that an astute giants fan if you lose
tonight is started is starting to you
know what these losses are kind of good
because we would maybe we end up with
the number one overall pick i mean look
at how much teams give up to trade up
you give up future first round picks you
give up current and future second round
picks you do what you have to do to get
in position to get the guys you want
wouldn't be great if you don't have to
give up extra stuff
to get to where you you want to be i
just i i think one in five if you're a
giants fan i know if i was a giants fan
i'd be thinking all right that's fine i
can deal with it i didn't expect much
this year anyway let's get justin
herbert or whoever the number one pick
ends up being and let's float eli
manning on an iceberg and just take it
from there i i hear you there like i'm
not like uh i'm i'm arguing against some
of your process of what you're saying
but yes as a true giants fan if they
lost tonight yeah i would certainly be
thinking like okay yep you know hey
maybe it's just better this way and we
move on to the next era the issue here
though in new york and i think stats
will tell you is i don't think giant
fans are ready to give up on eli manning
by any stretch of the imagination yet i
don't it's still a total defense of him
all the time so that's where i think
it's going to be really intriguing going
forward uh you know like the the
opportunity of what you're talking about
was there last year and they decided to
go with running back and keep riding
with eli manning until they felt like
both sides were ready to part ways and i
guess we're not at that point yet and i
certainly don't think the giants fans
are quite there yet so
that's going to be the big thing too
going forward and uh i have no idea
where it goes
as to the eagles yeah one thing that
they have not been doing well this year
in relation to last year especially in
the playoffs the run pass option doug
peterson addressed that yesterday
he said they're still using it as much
they're just not throwing as much out of
it they're running more out of it and i
think defenses are realizing hey their
running backs aren't great so we're
going to stay disciplined we're not
going to get burned and if if they end
up handing off the ball we'll deal with
that when it happens do you think that
that they are just simply an effective
running back away from reinvigorating
the rpo i i do yes i i mean i don't i
don't want to make it sound that simple
but you know last year this was an
offense it was one of the best rushing
offenses in football and that opened up
so much of their offense through that
this year
i would say
first of all the running back play has
been an issue especially with corey
clement getting hurt because i think he
was their best back before that jay
ajaye even before this acl injury has
been a little underwhelming and i think
he's going to continue to deal with a
knee issue for the rest of his career so
that's an issue they do need a running
back and then the second part of that to
me would also be doug peterson a little
bit i feel like doug peterson has gotten
past happy in some situations here the
last few weeks in football games where i
want to go man you just ran the ball for
eight eight yards through a huge hole
and then we throw the ball you know six
or seven plays in a row right after that
i feel like doug's also got to be a
little bit more patient and let his big
guys up front uh kind of wear on people
because that is one of their strengths
their offensive line and their size and
physicality hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports